of civil war every year on may 15th
palestinians around the world remember
nakba or the catastrophe
the day in 1948 israel was created in
palestine
this year in gaza al jazeera 2 marks the
one year anniversary of the israeli
bombing of a building housing its
offices
on the same date
that attack came as part of an 11-day
battle in gaza between israeli forces
and palestinian groups
it was the bloodiest conflict since
2014.
we were 30 apartments and 50 offices
were forcibly displaced in a single
night our hopes were high after we heard
of the donors funding for the
reconstruction but months passed and
nothing has been implemented yet
according to local officials israeli
forces targeted high-rise towers
apartment buildings and bombed thousands
of other sites
more than 260 people were killed and at
least 2 000 others were injured
basic services were severely disrupted
according to the ministry of housing in
gaza only 200 residential units have
been rebuilt
israel also destroyed 50 media offices
in gaza including al jazeera's
at the time
israel said hamas operatives were using
the building
but presented no solid evidence to back
this
claim we are certain that the person who
gave the order to strike and destroy
al-jala tower is the same person who
gave the order of breaking jivara's arm
and sheikh jarrah and is the same person
who gave the order of the assassination
of shireen abu ah
and he is the one who must be revealed
and presented to the international trial
today as we recall the memories of the
bombing of our gaza office
we are once again under attack
after the killing of our colleague
shireen abhakli who was covering an
israeli raid in janine
after a year of working from various
locations and temporary offices
al jazeera now has a new gaza beru
but gaza like the rest of the israeli
occupied territory has always been one
of the most difficult areas for
journalists to cover
but it has never deterred us from our
mission
to report the news
al jazeera gaza